but it's definitely a dream to like play
a superhero and to be a part of what
turned out to be something so incredible
and unlike anything else really is but
it feels pretty special hey guys my name
is Gwen Stacy for the last two years
I've been the one and only spider gram I
think the spider gram is so strong and
free-spirited and just a natural leader
and really unafraid to be you know in a
room full of people that are that as
well and and she's able to go walk into
a room like I said with people that you
know are also uniquely strong and
different in their own ways but she's
her own person and she's kind above all
she's she's a badass and she gets the
job done there's already talk about a
female spin-off let's just say
hypothetically what would that mean for
you to kind of helm that oh my goodness
I mean to be a part of this and play
this strong female superhero in this
film particularly is quite a privilege
um the thought of a spin-off is
incredible if that were to ever happen I
would be honored to be a part of it I'd
love that opportunity um any anything to
do something like this again with these
people would be with being on it I
remember seeing her for the first time
I'm feeling like this is the coolest
thing I've ever done and it was one of
those things where you know you hear
about you know the directors were so
excited about how she was coming
together and you know the color scheme
of her outfits or look as a whole they
were really excited about that was
coming together and I was hearing all
about it and then it was one of those
things I was like okay now they're gonna
show me a sketch and I'm gonna have to
act like it's great but I'm not gonna
know what that means and sure enough
when they showed it to me it was pretty
final what they showed me and and again
like I said it was like this is the
coolest thing ever and too bad this
isn't live-action because I wish I
actually looked like that
[Music]